est ce que tu veux bien regarder la
caméra et faire clap
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour kevin langeree c'est un merci de
m'avoir accordé cet entretien chez toi à
kde est ce que tu voudrais te présenter
pour les personnes qui ne connaîtraient
pas et nous dire pourquoi nous sommes
ici aujourd'hui
alors me présenter les eaux je m'appelle
kevin g 32 ans j'habite à cannes donc
j'ai vécu plusieurs années une dizaine
d'années en russie
donc quelque part tu as je suis français
et par dans l'âme quelques pardon ni mes
copains en russie jeu presque
franco-russe tu vois en quelque sorte
adecco maurice devrait pas joe mcknight
au vide n'a d'yeux shops hewitt à achat
du coup donc ça c'est voilà en tant qu'
en tant que personne physique et sinon
je suis joueur d'échecs j'ai commencé
les échecs quand j'avais 6 ans et demi
ça temps j'ai appris sur une gameboy
parce que mon père avait en fait il
avait failli on amène game boy et mon
père a toujours joué aux échecs et ils
avaient plus d'adversaires entre gay pas
trop le temps mais il a il y avait
acheté une cassette pour jouer aux
échecs et en fait c'est le jeu sur la
game boy des mario de tous qui avez
c'est le jeu qui m'a intrigué le plus
c'est le jeu auquel j'avais envie de
jouer et donc à force de lui dire j'ai
envie de jouer à cette casse tête j'ai
envie de jouer à cette cachette ils me
voyaient s'est déplacé les pions et
j'essaie de comprendre par déduction
comment bouger des pièces donc un jour
il m'a pris et m'a mis un échiquier m'a
dit bon je vais t'apprendre à jouer et
du coup cette vie ce jour là que je suis
devenu joueur d'échecs et s'inquiètent
pas rapporte eu avec le gaming
finalement tous fichés tout faire un
truc
écoute je te propose qu'on veut juste ça
quant au favori thèse on va revenir on
re développement sur haïti c'est très
intéressant et on va l'histoire
présentation ça disons que c'est
important précisé que tu as une chaîne
youtube
oui qui s'appelle bitstream voilà donc
je vais le lire dans la description et
pour toutes les personnes qui seraient
intéressées d'aller visiter cette chaîne
et est abonnée ou alors ce que tu peux
nous expliquer un peu ce que tu fais sur
cette chaîne bah je fais on va dire de
la vulgarisation et chicken mais
vulgarisation est à la fois très
qualitatif c'est à dire que c'est de la
vulgarisation dans le ton ça c'est
détente drôle
enfin j'espère c'est drôle que pour
presse de bonnes vibes et vivre c'est
drôle en tout cas pour moi et les
quelques personnes qui suivent qui ont
un humour évidemment ne peuvent par
ailleurs mais voilà c'est oui pu être
formaté comme une merde [ __ ] tony j'y
peux rien j'y peux rien à tony c'est
dans l'esprit je fais pas exprès ou à
chaque foulée de l'échec se force à
revenir ici je te prends ta tour tu peux
pas reprendre une cavale toni galles
futur temps tony est obligé d'abandonner
tony hale et revient en revanche sur ce
qu'on raconte sur les échecs c'est assez
qualitative parce que je fais ça elles
m'ont déjà moins qu'il ya un certain
niveau mais je suis pas grand maître je
suis juste un bon joueur mais j'ai des
collègues qui me rejoignent souvent donc
fabien vous avez pu voir si vous suivez
la chaîne qui est grand maître
sélections en équipe de france là qui
étaient dans les meilleurs mondiaux
et donc on fait un ton ultra décalé
humour marange alors c'est pas sérieux
et sur la qualité de ce qu'on présente
sur les analystes ce qu'on fait on
essaye de faire le mieux qu'on peut donc
on présente les parties comme si on
parlait à des joueurs de haut niveau en
fait des princes et cas donc je prends
le pion il va normalement jouer 4 et je
ferai le g5 pour tuer le clouage du fou
sur le cavalier puis ensuite b5 pour
protéger le pion c4 ça c'est le plan les
amis on va voir on va voir ce qui se
passe en réalité alors sans prétention
mais sans fausse modestie aussi est ce
que tu peux donner l'idée de ton niveau
donc jasmin et de dos rond titre en tant
que joueur d'échecs alors mon niveau en
fait j'ai arrêté de jouer en compétition
officielle à l'âge de 18 ans pile donc à
18 ans et un mois ou deux mois mon
niveau c'était 2300 fidh et ça doit
représenter top 200 français je pense
quelque chose comme ça dans les
catégories jeunes genre en moins de 14
ans moins de 16 ans 12 ans je devais
être dans le top 5 français donc avant
que j'arrête
et donc voilà on y voir de près c'est
pour préciser pour les personnes qui ne
connaissent pas on n'est pas juste un
amateur petits joueurs déjà qu dimanche
qui aime bien les échecs et qui du coup
a ouvert une chaîne youtube sur sur les
échecs on est d'accord avec ça ouais
ouais je suis pas un joueur puis
dimanche et justine assez incroyable tu
sais contre qui fait en train de jouer
c'est juste ouf
c'est pas juste un jeu contre le
champion du monde d'échecs a quand même
sa première fois dans ma vie
faut juste faire le vide dans la tête on
joue contre un mec lambda on va lui
défoncer sa mère ya ce qu on appelait du
cougaing sel on a fait du castel alors
tu disais que tu avais découvert les
échecs par les jeux vidéo en fait ouais
par la game boy est ce que tu penses que
si tu les avais découvert autrement donc
sur un plateau des chèques classique
est-ce que nous tu l'aurais vécu de la
même façon à ce que tu aurais eu autant
de passion ouais je pense que ça
n'aurait pas changé grand chose en
réalité je pense que récuse découvert
par un jeu vidéo sur un plateau ça
aurait été pareil parce que j'ai
toujours aimé les problèmes résultent
des problèmes techniques j'étais petit
en fait j'aimerais bien qu'on me donne
des casse-tête et la résolution de
problèmes m'a toujours plu
et au final des échecs c'est qu'une
suite de problèmes que tu donnes ton
adversaire et tu finis par résoudre face
et ça en fait c'est la résolution de
problèmes tu vois je posais pas mon
adversaire il me reposer peas le premier
qui elle participe à résoudre mais il va
être mal mais donc ouais je pense que sa
mort est plus pareil après qu'est ce que
j'aurais découvert les échecs
s'il n'y avait pas eu les jeux vidéo ça
je ne saurai jamais parce que bien sûr
une part définie par définition fait pas
l'histoire à l'envers
juste pour faire une idée sur des
représentations tu as aussi un site
internet
et si je ne m'abuse tué professeur
trichet lui donne des cours pour les
jeunes beaucoup de cours en ligne
ouais ouais enfin je donnais beaucoup de
cours en ligne danger de moins en moins
de temps donc je fais de moins en moins
d'élèves mais ouais je donne des cours
en ligne
alors je le dis pour deux raisons
d'abord pour faire depuis cité quand
même parce que ça certainement et aussi
pour dire qu' il ya un point qui nous
relient c'est l'enseignement
oui donc la pédagogie et je pense que
c'est une des caractéristiques important
de taschen la pédagogie donc ça on aura
l'occasion d'en parler
un ouf alors que j'avais dsit pas déjà
si c'est le choix des choses à dire
alors donc tu as découvert les échecs
tuer des enfants
on dit souvent que les échecs c'est un
jeu compliqué c'est un jeu difficile
d'accès et est-ce que tu pars faire cet
avis notamment pour les enfants
toi tu l'a découvert étant enfant ce jeu
mais est ce que tu penses que c'est un
jeu trop difficile pour les enfants
alors là qu'on doit être simple mais
développer non c'est pas trop difficile
j'ai eu donner des cours à genève dans
les écoles
des élèves qui étaient équivalents du
ce1 ce2 en france et quand tu vas dans
une classe que tu vas apprendre les
échecs à des gamins de cet âge là en
fait ils accrochent presque tous donc tu
avais classes de 25 élèves en suisse en
grommelant peut-être 20 20 à 21 un ton
qui tacle vendre autant à 15 sur 20 qui
vont vraiment accroché je pense que
c'est une bonne moyenne pour une matière
en général et les gamins quand tu leur
dis à la fin du cours les vingt
dernières minutes tu les laisses un peu
joué 15 20 minutes pour qu'il pratique
parce que sinon c'est un peu pénible
ta personne qui veut pas jouer tu as
tous les enfants qui jouent ils
communiquent entre eux donc
même ceux qui ont un peu de mal qui
jouent moins bien quand même il rigole
avec les autres fans en fait c'est pas
non c'est vraiment pas compliqué ils
savent déplacer les pièces juste le truc
important c'est la vision des choses
c'est de faire en sorte en tant que prof
de faire les choses simplement
c'est à dire que pour te donner un
exemple 5 pour ceux qui savent jouer aux
échecs quand j'apprends à des enfants de
cet âge là à jouer
il ya une règle qui est très difficile à
comprendre c'est l'échec et mat pourquoi
parce que l'échec et mat on explique aux
échecs le plus c'est de manger
l'adversaire de l'autre et après on te
dit oui mais alors attention il faut pas
manger le roi de l'adversaire il faut le
mettre et chaque et max alors là on
t'explique échec et mat
c2c de bloquer le roi adverse pour qui
les deux cases mais alors attention tu
expliques que le pat c'est quand le roi
adverse est bloqué mais que en fait tu
peux pas le manger donc là en fait le
gamin si tu lui explique tout ça à 8 9
ans il va dire non mais allez c'est bon
mais si tu lui dis le but c'est de
manger droit tu fais ce que tu veux tu
m'explique pas le bateau début 1 après
2,6 qui vient il étudie vous jouez donc
en général moi ce que je faisais ses
premières leçons du chaos avec des pions
donc ta que les plus encore à sa phase
d'ajustement j'ai posé la question mais
bon on l'attendait apprenantes madeleine
je le sentais arriver donc là tu as
répondu à trois questions que je prends
rien imposé mais du coup on va y revenir
à chaque fois notamment sur cette
particularité du jeu d'échecs qui
consiste à vaincre l'autre non pas en
allant jusqu'au bout mais en s'arrêtant
au moment juste avant finalement les
savoirs maison on reparlera parisien on
n'a rien
j'allais poser la question toute bête tu
dois apprendre un enfant 6 ans a joué
aux échecs
comment tu commence alors pas juste je
sens que j'avais développé
donc on va on va partir du principe
qu'on est avec un groupe d'enfants parce
que pour une raison simple bon quand on
est tout seul c'est un peu donc on peut
le faire en deux parties mais on va
partir avec un groupe d'enfants parce
qu'en général quand même les échecs
c'est un jeu et comme tous les jeux il
faut plusieurs partenaires et donc quand
à plusieurs partenaires tard on va dire
qu'on ait au moins deux d'accord ont
néanmoins deux enfants première chose
que tu fais tu apprends à bouger le roi
pourquoi parce que c'est en fait c'est
la pièce la plus importante est sans roi
tu peux pas jouer deuxième pièce que moi
j'apprenais que que j'apprends quand
j'ai un enfant face de moi c'est les
pions c'est un peu technique parce qu'il
ya des règles où il avance une caste de
quasiment jandilla gonal mais les
enfants sont pas débiles quand même il
faut se dire qu'ils sont intelligents
alors parler comme à des personnes
intelligentes qu'ils apprennent très
vite et ils le font très bien
on évite juste la prise en passant parce
que c'est un peu compliqué on y revient
on fait des trucs basiques et là on peut
déjà jouer un jeu première leçon on
arrête là pas besoin de faire plus
premier jeu trois pions contre roye
pions le premier qui arrive au bout on
vous dit même pas confié une dame 1 le
premier qui arrive au bout a gagné la
partie
donc là déjà les gamins ils ont passé
vingt trente minutes avec toi il joue
déjà tu vois c'est ça qui est important
c'est les échecs c'est un jeu ça je le
dirai jamais assez et je le répèterai
plein de fois c'est on appelle ça jouer
aux échecs c'est pas je fais de la
compétition pour être le plus fort aux
échecs c'est un verbe s'est joué donc tu
joues tu fais ça deuxième leçon tu vas
pas très loin tu apprends les tours au
pied tour et si les mecs les gamins sont
un peu bon tu vois c'est bon tu rajoutes
les fous allez on fait une partie avec
les tours les fous leroy et on joue
pareil on essaie d'aller à dame au début
tu rajoutes les cavaliers tu rajoutes
les dames au cours d'après et là tu peux
commencer quand à toutes les pièces à
dire maintenant on va plus aller
jusqu'au bout avec le pion qui se
transformer en dame
on essaiera de longer le roi adverse du
coup les gamins ils continuent à
s'amuser c'est de manger le roi de
l'hers et puis après tu rajoutes le maté
vaincu le fait petit à petit on va
progressivement mais important de les
faire jouer rapidement et qui soit
capable de faire la partie situera enfin
pour moi a prêché kaeppelin gens qui
sont pas d'accord avec ça mais si tu
commences à rajouter le mat le pâté tout
ça tu frustre des gamins pour moi par
exemple que mon père m'a appris
c'était pas la peine
faire ça comme ça parce que j'ai été
assez doué monde oui d'accord vi nations
des spécificités selon les élèves qui
font que tu peux aller plus ou moins
vite mais divers général je brûle pas
les étapes et ses manques tu dis ça
parce que ça ça nous fait un vrai point
commun entre un de pédagogie c'est vrai
que souvent quand jeanne élèves à qui je
dois expliquer quelque chose de complexe
gelé volontairement occulté des
informations pour être sûr qu'ils
comprennent ce que je les lui
transmettre complète et ensuite je dis
avec lui voient en fait je fais pas tu
dis ça aussi ça rit ça tu le fait
qu'après vous parce que si tu lui dis de
manière anticipée le gamin il s'est plus
jamais laisser fait il ce noir il donc
les avants ne s'est pas que le jouet est
compliqué jeu d'échec c'est plutôt qu'il
faut y aller par ap apprend qu'il est
prend le temps s'amuser parce que c'est
un jeu est en fait c'est vraiment le
lait de narbonne jouer s'amuser jouer et
s'amuser ça doit toujours le le le coeur
de ton enseignement un monde de mon
point de vu au début quand ce échec
c'est vraiment que tu t'amuses c1 je
sais on est là pour s'amuser en fait on
est là bas c'est pas moi je commençais
de tennis ya pas longtemps je prends des
cours de tennis je suis une catastrophe
absolue mais une catastrophe downpour
prof de tennis et il regarde guide fort
que je vais bien je sais que je le sais
mais mais je kiffe affectif mais je m'en
fiche de mettre les voiles dehors ou
quoi je suis très heureux tu as je tape
dedans et ça envoie beaucoup dans tes
vidéos d'ailleurs c'est que c'est le
plaisir qui domine
bien sûr elle s'il ya aussi la
compétition de bon sens ça fait partie
de sa vie
le plaisir de montrer à l'autre qu'on
lui est supérieur en tout cas le temps
d'une partie et ça fait partie du jeu et
c'est vrai que c'est une bombe aux antes
essentiels dans la transmission est ce
que j'avais quelque chose à rajouter
là-dessus à jure l'apprentissage des
échecs aux enfants non maintenant du
coup les enfants adorent les échecs
jouit pour ajouter et après les enfants
nous quand tu les fais jouer comme ça
ils adorent tu en a beaucoup qui
accroche ceux qui ont du mal avec les
règles ils se rendent pas trop content
parce que du coup les autres qui sont
plus forts ils comprennent peinture et
les enfants ils sont intelligents
ça c'est oui ça m'a churn qui s'adapte
et du coup tout le monde s'amuse
ensemble tout le monde joue et c'est un
moyen de communiquer en fait de relier
les gens c'est important ça aussi ouais
en très intéressant ok alors revenons
maintenant sur cette originalité du jeu
d'échecs que tu évoquais donc je disais
j'ai envie d'être bien clair dans la
question si elle est bizarre tu le dit
le président on ne gagne pas en prenant
le roi en le mangeant on gagne
en mettant le roi dans l'impossibilité
d'empêcher comprennent exactement bon
donc c'est comme si la partie s'arrêter
juste avant je disais la mise à mort du
roi juste avant
voilà est ce que tu t'es déjà interrogé
sur cette particularité jeu d'échecs qui
fait qu'on ne gagne pas en gagnant on
gagne en empêchant l'autre de pouvoir
gagner
comment tu vas interpress alors j'ai
toujours une interprétation qui m'a paru
logique est simple à la fois je sais pas
si elle est vrai j'ai pas vérifié
historiquement mais dans mon
interprétation personnelle j'ai toujours
dit que le roi c'est plus puissant on
est d'accord légal du roi blanc c'est le
roi noir cité un roi et tu dois faire
des lois en faveur des noirs
internationale tu vas bien sûr faire une
loi ou tout le monde
enfin les autres sont pas protégés parce
que c'est un peu de la chair à canon
peut enfin se dégager quoi en fait toi
tu vas te dire oui bon bah je vais faire
un accord avec les autres rois alors
diront si jamais les mecs ça se passe
vraiment mal of savent à quoi on se fait
prisonnier un peu comme napoléon quand
il a quand il a eu un été prisonnier tu
vas y vivait tranquille quoi tu
prisonniers de guerre tu viens au buffet
et tu manges tu ne fais plus de
politique
mais en fait tout le reste enfin la vie
quotidienne se dérouler sans
interpellation il va encore plus bizarre
que ma question à l'isaf était allé
trouver une signification au niveau
politique
en gros les rois n'ont aucun intérêt à
s'entretuer bah oui enfin on est égaux
donc on va se faire des règles pour pour
que pour nous si jamais ça se passe pas
trop mal quand même
et ensuite on cache une fois qu'elle à
l'emprisonnement ouais on gâche le la
suite au public web montre parce qu'il
se bat non non non non non parce qu'ils
soient jamais on leur montre jamais ce
qui se passe de toute façon je pensais
pas que ça allait aussi loin mais c'est
parfait mais ça m'a toujours face ça m'a
toujours paru hyper logique en fait
ouais c'est vrai que dans la plupart des
joueurs on imagine que la partie
s'arrête quand le roi est mort alors
comme on en parlait dans la voiture en
venant c'est vrai que ça ça nuit un peu
à la qualité du jeu c'est à dire que
l'héroïne suspense s'il suffit de
prendre le roi layan plus de suspense si
le roi peut se défendre besson a préféré
renoncer quand tu joues un peu bien
après enfin séparé fin pour nous c'est
pareil ouais ouais pour nous qui jouons
que tu as impulsé en fait d' avance
d'accord mais à
mais en fait il faut savoir que enfin
les joueurs d'échecs de plus par jour à
jack et qui j'ai parlé quand on pense
que le roi c'est nous en fait sur
l'échiquier le roi c'est toi en fait
c'est toi qui te déplaces la fin du coup
je veux bien te protéger dans le coin
des lois et précis jamais dû perdre
d'abord envie qu'on te tue quand même
pas le droit c'est toi deux canoës
signification alors et quiz embrayons
directement la suce moi j'ai une
question de néophytes en fait je ne sais
pas josé chacun je le confesse platement
qu'est ce qui explique cette
extraordinaire pouvoir de la dame est ce
si faible pouvoir contre les guillemets
du roi là en terme de déplacement bien
sûr ça s'explique ex historiquement a
alors juste pour ceux qui ne connaissent
absolument qu'ils connaissent encore
moins que moi aux échecs
est ce que tu peux nous expliquer le
pouvoir un seul peut faire la règle sur
l'échiquier ce que peut faire l'europe
alors le roi il se déplace d'une case
autour de lui donc il à faible pouvoir
de déplacement la dame elle se déplace
d'autant de casque à lever autour
d'arles dans quelle peut toucher
énormément de théâtre je me rappelle
plus la de mémoire conduire maximum elle
peut toucher quasiment toutes les cases
de l'échiquier
on n'en sait rien elle est très heureuse
mais c'est une explication historique
en réalité la dame fait les échecs ça
vient de perth et chez les pères c'était
un vizir et le vizir c'était la pièce la
plus faible je crois parce qu'elle se
déplaçait que d'une case en diagonale
ensuite le jeu arrive en espagne le
viseur est devenue la dame
enfin la reine à l'époque et de mémoire
vérifier dans les commentaires c'est une
bêtise historique et que c'est pas exact
exact mais telle mais l arène dans
d'espagne elle a pas trop compris vers
parce qu'elle était très puissante en
espagne et là elle bouge et que nier 15
en diagonale
donc elle n'a pas trop compris ce délire
là elle a dit bonjour on chante l'air
malin je bouge de partout
je me déplace c'est catherine de rennes
devoir de la red c'est un caprice de
femmes je te laisse pas débuter une
reine un candidat musulman où je
comprenais pas j'en ai je tendais dire
d'un milliard d'âmes dans tes parties
d'échecs et d'autre et du coup je juin
où il tient à ce qu'il faut dire dawa
c'est un truc ou deux joueurs d'échecs
veut dire en français on dit dame en
anglais on dit quinn oui tu vois suivant
les langues pareil ça dépend des langues
et même même les autres pièces suivant
les langues par exemple en français on
dit un fou oui en russe ça va être sloan
ça va être un éléphant voilà donc en
français on va avoir une tour en russie
ça va être un bateau donc alors parlons
ça faisait un petit peu de ça aussi je
vais me lancer sur les interprétations
totalement délirante que je veux des
fêtes un jour sur le jour le fou il se
déplace en diagonale bon maintenant si
on se met en géométrie on prend par
exemple un rectangle ondra ça vient
bonhomme ouais ok la diagonale
c'est le trajet le plus court entre les
deux points opposés au lit d'accord et
quand on prend un triangle rectangle de
côté 1 le la diagonale donne à nourrir
rationnelle et jusqu'à un stage savais
pas voilà et le nombre irrationnel
j'ai pas pu m'empêcher si tu veux de
penser à irrationnelle soi et souvent
les gens qu'on dit fou donc il rationnel
ils prennent des chemins beaucoup plus
direct que nous qui résonneront
n'inquiète pas l inverse un accès
beaucoup plus rapide aux alors ça
c'était une réflexion que je n'ai
défaite survenant sur le fou mais je
n'ai pas appliqué aux autres pièces
est ce que toi tu t'es déjà interrogé
est ce que tu as des interprétations ou
des connaissances par rapport au nom des
pièces à leur rôle et à leur
signification
alors je peux te dire que j'ai des
lacunes par rapport à ça parce que ça
fait un moment que j'ai plus j'eus eu
certaines raisons pour lesquelles les
pièces avaient un sens ou un autre mais
honnêtement
je sais juste pas je sais juste plus
mais dans toutes les langues s'est
traduit de manière différente et à
chaque fois il ya des histoires mais
mais honnêtement je suis pas la bonne
personne pour te répondre à ça je sais
qu'il ya une littérature là dessus je
sais que ça a été écrit
moi j'ai quand même eu la chance de
rencontrer une personne qui s'appelle du
rire verbard qui est le plus grand
historien échiquier en vie en fait et je
l'avais rencontré parce que je
travaillais à moscou on voulait éviter
justement de ces livres sur l'histoire
des échecs donc que j'avais pu lire
et moi j'avais l'impression qu'en
français on avait beaucoup de pièces
qu'ils pouvaient être liés aux templiers
même sur même sur le design des pièces
en avait discuté avec lui je lui disais
par exemple que la croix du roi ça me
faisait penser aux jeux pan cependant ce
beau et ça en france c'est parce que le
drapeau obtenu les templiers
vous avez un grand drapeau comme ça et
quand il faisait tomber le drapeau ça
veut dire que voulait se replier et
gillet c'est marrant parce qu'en fait le
sur le royal à petit croix c'est pareil
que le drapeau des templiers et aux
échecs on a parfois un signe c'est quand
on m'a abandonné on fait on fait tomber
le roi comme ça quoi sur le clic est un
peu comme si on faisait tomber le
drapeau templiers pour dire que on se
parlait mecque et même au niveau de la
circulation la tour c'est un peu ce que
construisez des templiers construit des
tours et joué dans des tours le fou
c'est en anglais c'est un bishop
c'est un religieux donc là encore les
cavaliers bas ok le chevalier quoi
forcément et du coup j'avais
l'impression que quand le jeu est
dépassée 2 pers à l'europe qui avait une
une influence des templiers sur les
échecs et même dangereux que c'est dans
une église en écosse
aujourd'hui donc vous savez quand même
un rapport avec les templiers à cette
époque là et sur les vitraux il ya des
gens qui jouent aux échecs
donc j'ai eu l'impression qu'il y avait
eu une une une influence assez forte
quand je les venues chez nous deux de
ces personnes qui ont fait les croisades
donc quelque part qui ont ramené une
partie de partie de l'héritage culturel
et donc je vais discuter avec avec il
monsieur youri aberbach et il avait
trouvé en la théorie pas du tout
officiel mais mais magique c'est une
théorie intéressante et que ça aurait pu
avoir le mérite
s'il avait été plus jeunes
d'y réfléchir parce qu'il m'a dit que ça
paraissait pas idiot mais voilà c'est
eric complètement personnel qui n'a vu
ses parts à cheveux ces personnels ou
farfelues que c'est pas intéressant ça
pourrait mériter un ca pourrait mériter
un approfondissement de ma part plus
tard mais pas pour le moment
et au niveau historique donc les échecs
qui nous a dit que ça venait de perth
ouais et ça vient même encore avant que
le jeu qui est percé vient d'inde en
fait d'un don qui est bien prendre terre
ce qui a changé ici on peut parler de ça
ouais ça m'intéresserait en fait se
situe le son on va faire un petit peu la
généalogie ce jeu savoir aussi dans quel
contexte il est apparu à de jeunes
enfants je sais un petit peu alors là
encore si les gens commentaires qui
savent plus que moi c'est plus au
dernier il ya des gens à des
spécialistes des historiens des échecs
irna il dit n'hésite pas à se manifester
complètement complètement et ce sera
même avec plaisir que je lirai leur
correctement faute au contraire
mais de ce que je sais ça vient d'un jeu
qui s'appelait lé château grand gars qui
veut dire je pense en indiens les quatre
châteaux et ça se joue à deux contre
deux par équipe et il y avait un dea en
fait qui décide et de quelles pièces
allaient se déplacer et donc sauver sa
joie de comptes de en équipe et d'après
ce que je sais quand tu avais un joueur
d'une équipe d'une des deux équipes qui
perdait après les mecs se joue en deux
contre en un contre un de la même équipe
c'était genre une double guerre sert
qu'en fait genre où on était face à face
donc on joue ensemble on veut contre les
mecs il y avait les châteaux comme ça ça
faisait un genre de rectangles et en
fait quand on avait battu l'équipe des
mecs à côté on se battaient entre eux
pour pour remporter la mise
avec d'abord et du coup c'est hyper
chaud parce que peut-être qu'à un moment
la partie le mec qui est ont allié en
fait peut-être c'est pas très
intéressant de battre l'équipe adverse
maintenant parce que sinon lui va te
mets un peu comme dans la guerre en
réalité là c'est un peu chaud mais ça
joue avec un dessin jouer de l'argent
il se trouve que le jeu après donc de
chatou envers donc ce jeu là il arrivait
en perse il est devenu châtre anges et à
l'époque il était interdit de miser de
l'argent à cause de l'art
jean et de jouer à des jeux de hasard et
donc ils ont changé du deux contre deux
à un contre un et c'est devenu le chatte
range donc c'était un jeu avec des
règles un tout petit peu différents
genres le fou pouvait bouger que deux
cases en diagonale complètement la dame
s'était vision en a parlé tout à l'heure
une case en diagonale les plus avancés
que d'une 4 avoir plusieurs règles donc
ce jeu-là perdurer même encore on
connaît on en connaît les règles et des
gens qui connaissent la règle de ce
qu'ils sont capables d'y jouer juste on
y joue plus vraiment et après donc il
arrive en europe
on peut à juste un peu avant les
croisades je pense que ça a commencé
puis après ça c'est encore plus plus
développé et il petit à petit on arrive
au règlement d'aujourd'hui avec la dame
qui a changé déplacement le petit robe
qui arrive et il est quelques petits
changements mineurs non on va dire que
le jeu après il est venu chez nous et il
est parti au japon et en asie dans la
direction où il est parti en asie ça a
donné
le shogi au japon ce qu'on pourrait
appeler les échecs japonais et le client
xix en chine est-ce que ça me bloque la
peinture raconte ça c'est que c'est un
jeu universel au sens où c'était pas un
jeu qui est inscrit dans des limites
culturel
non ça jeu auquel tout le monde peut
jouer tout le monde peut en comprendre
le sens on vous dit ça pourquoi parce
que souvent quand on va un peu voir les
jeux traditionnels de tel pays ou des
thèmes culture parfois on va avoir une
sorte de réaction un petit peu voilà mon
que c'est très chauvine de se dire mais
qu'est ce que c'est que ce jeu ils ont
des drôles d'idées
alors voilà c'est bien logique à une
certaine universalité comme si
finalement la tournure d'esprit que
requièrent les échecs étaient quelque
chose d'universel qui était pas
culturelle c'est un beau jeu quoi c'est
pas de moi c'est mon copain femme qui
n'a pas mis ce sens un beau jeu va
est-ce que
la logique et le munci principal pour
être bon et cheikh où s il faut autre
chose
[Musique]
malheureusement faudra être très bon
joueur d'échecs arue niveau en tout cas
c'est surtout visualisation calcul
ouais reconnaissance de schéma c'est à
dire tu répètes des trucs que tu as pris
donc mais moi tu répètes les parties que
tu as vu que tu as beaucoup étudié tu
répètes ce que tu as vu donc ta bonne
mémoire tu visualise bien parce que pour
pouvoir se rappeler de la position il
faut avoir une bonne visualisation en
l'espace des pouvoirs fait on a tous un
échiquier à l'inter de la terre c'est ce
que tu fais toi avant tu es en train de
réfléchir à ce que tu vas faire
ouais tu regardes pas le l'échiquier tu
regardes les défaillances chez qui les
idées là en fait il est là j aimerais et
les pièces anormal bougez vous des fois
qu'on n'était pas très en forme elle ne
bouge plus mais normalement elle doit
bouger là est normalement l'échiquier
je parlais avec mon copain en fait on a
tous mais chic et normalement avec les
blancs bas en fait j'ai pas dans ma tête
on est chic et je peux pas le mettre
dans l'autre sens il est pas dans le
sens du jeu de la forme ou le mien il
est plutôt avec les plans bas si j'ai
réfléchi une position je vais avoir les
blancs bas donc on à l'échiquier donc
visualisation quand même pour pouvoir la
voir en tête et après calcul parce qu'il
faut le faire bouger
il faut le faire bouger vite comme faire
bouger loin il faut pas faire de
conneries quand il bouge ça quand tu
calcules faut que la paix est ce que toi
qui calcule des positions et
déplacements ou est-ce que ça se fait et
j'en suis à 6tu dans ton dans son esprit
un peu les deux lettres qui sont très
intuitifs qui vont très vite parce que
c'est facile
donc quoi des fois ça se passe tout seul
intuitivement genre en fait la tactique
je la connais tellement bien tu peux
aimer un truc que ton cerveau il fa
automates faire la réponse en fait elle
devient tout de suite tout seul c'est
ben voilà ça se fait naturellement
mais parfois pour trouver le bon coup tu
vas devoir instauré moi ce que
j'appellerais après c'est peut-être pour
tout le monde personnel
mais ce que j'appellerais une discussion
interne genre tiens
la position est plutôt fermé les
cavaliers sont plus forts que c'est fou
essayons d'amener les cavaliers sur tel
car est ce que tu vas discute avec toi
même et puis tu vas tu vas créer un
raisonnement par tous comme un ouais tu
crées une problématique tu trouves le
problème tu pose ta question
et puis après tu essayes de répondre à
la question par le calcul et tu vas voir
ce cheminement de pensée de discussion
qui doit retrouver en philosophie
n'achète pas tu te relèves totalement
battu valeo de l'expression de
discussion à l'intérieur on va les
salles à la délibération que même la
réflexion tout simplement mexes et c'est
ça c'est la discussion avec soi même et
je pense que c'est un truc on retrouve
aussi dans les échecs alors moi je joue
par aux échecs même si le joueur
lui-même et l'esprit du jeu ne me plaît
je j'avoue quand en face ici j'ai pas
franchi le pas de jouer aux échecs c'est
parce que il ya tellement de
possibilités et il ya tellement besoin
d'anticiper à long terme qu'au bout d'un
moment je trouve que j'ai pas le
matériau tu vois dans l'instrumental
c'est hervé d'aller là parce que je
pense quand même qu'il faut avoir un bon
équipement cognitifs ou a fait lecture
elle pour tenir la cadence
alors il faut un bon équipement
intellectuelle pour bien jouer pour très
bien joué wen est pas pour s'amuser pas
pour s'amuser
attention c'est vrai c'est très
important a déjà c'est-à-dire les hyper
important de préciser ce que tu vas tu
as des gens qui te disent j'ai pas envie
de commencer chaque c'est trop compliqué
bon les règles c'est facile à apprendre
et s'amuser il faut pas forcément bien
joué donc est ce qu'on peut paraître
est-ce que ça t'arrive et déjà pour
rentrer un peu dans l'anecdotique de
tomber sur des adversaires des
partenaires de jeu ils ont avec qui tu
t'es vraiment pas du tout amusé quittons
soûlé et en se disant voilà j'ai perdu
mon temps non
ouais ça m'arrivait plus plus sur le
tard qu'en jouant compétition dans les
partis qui sont longues se départit qui
dure jusqu'à 6 ou 7 heures et c'est une
des raisons pour lesquelles j'ai arrêté
je pense que je m'amusais plus tout
simplement né savent n'est pas forcément
de l'adversaire ou quoi c'est juste le
format de jeu c'était trop long alors
après ouais t'as des gens qui adorent
ses passes pas une critique par rapport
aux gens qui aident les parties très
longues ou quoi mais moi car très
clairement oui je me disais que rester
assis devant cette heure pour jouer une
partie d'échecs c'était non ça ça allait
pas en fait il est ce que tu apprends à
connaître une personne on joue avec nos
échecs c'est une question compliquée ça
c'est une question très compliquée mais
je me suis rendu compte que pour moi
même ce que c'était plus facile voire
par rapport à mon jeu et de me
comprendre moi je joue un peu de la même
manière à tous les jeux un peu de la
même manière et mon style change un peu
avec la russie de jeu mais j'ai
l'impression que mon style de jeu
correspond pas à ma personnalité dans la
vie de tous les jours donc j'ai
l'impression qu'en fait tu connais la
personne 30 joueurs mais pas en tant que
personne j'ai des bleus le joueur n'est
qu'un aspect avec une facette de ma
personnalité
personnellement c'est ce que je pense en
fait que je pense en tout cas moi je
suis quelqu'un quand vous j'aime bien
attaquer j'aime bien être agressif et
j'aime pas laisser passer une chance
voilà j'aime bien tuer des gens et je
m'accroche la faune non sur tempo va
regagner deux pions blum dégage dégage
bourhis boom tu apprends des nouveautés
dans la scandinave n'a même jamais vu de
ta vie vous g5 dans la scandinave du
décalage alors le côté que je m'accroche
la faune machin ça je peux le garder
mais dans la vie de tous les jours je
suis pas du tout une personne agressive
tu vois je réfléchis à tuer une mouche
tu vois fin ça m'embête de twin j'ai
personnellement fait un peu bizarre ce
truc d'aymeric caron ya pas longtemps
mais j'ai vite toi je préfère la faire
sortir ou quoi ça me fait mal au coeur
en fait de même deux tu as un insecte si
je suis pas obligé sauf les moustiques
non ça je laisse pas envie mais et alors
qu aux échecs je suis agressif donc mais
je sais pas je parle passion dans la vie
que j'ai envie d'agresser quelqu'un que
je souhaite du mal à quelqu'un ou quoi
je suis plutôt quelqu'un de bienveillant
en fait mais quand joseph
agressive donc pas je pense que c'est
une grosse association déjà peut-être
peut-être te répondrais que chaque être
humain une barre d'agressivité qui
l'expriment d'une façon ou d'une autre
et que toi tu les expriment à travers
les échecs
tout à fait c'est suffisant pour
l'évacuer dans et dans tous les jeux en
fait parce que quand je joue au poker
j'ai un style assez agressif aussi et
puis si tu mets sur n'importe quel jeu
vidéo quoi que je commence à jouer face
juste rêvant de même au tennis tu vas tu
me donnes une balle qui est un peu moins
juqu'à il faut que je prenne ma chance
si je marque pas maintenant j'ai envie
d'être entreprenants de faire quelque
chose mais c'est ouais j'ai dans le jeu
je sais de par là et peut-être way juste
mais là tu as peut-être c'est peut-être
pas un ancien prof de philo là quand
même
oh bah ouais parce qu'en fait un tête
qu'on pourrait se dire que peut-être
qu'on pourrait dire que dans la vie de
tous les jours je me l'a interdit parce
que j'ai pas envie de faire de mal à
autrui
donc je me l'auto interdire
intérieurement inconsciemment ou
consciemment et du coup en fait cette
part là ouais quand il n'ya plus d'enjeu
je la laisse peut-être peut-être donc
c'est ça reste là encore une hypothèse
interprétation possible qu'il veut avant
ils sont soit mais c'est vrai que
souvent aussi que le jeu c'est une
métaphore de la guerre c'est une guerre
où la violence est en conséquence
c'est-à-dire que une fois que la partie
est terminée on va pas se taper dessus
non c'est taper dessus symboliquement
way et puis voir le jeune voilà par la
partie et d'une certaine manière on
expulse on exprime on extériorise cette
violence et on la sublime à travers le
jeu et même c'est valable
les jeunes importe les sports ont par
exemple en boxe ouais là on se tape sur
le ring pour ne pas se taper à
l'extérieur elle était d'ailleurs
pendant la cloche sonne pour indiquer la
fin du combat
les deux adversaires se prennent dans
les bras l'un de l'autre
ouais c'est parce qu'ils ont ils
ressentent un respect l'un pour l'autre
après avoir encaissé ce qui se sont fait
subir mais du coup ça veut dire qu'une
fois qu'on a terminé qu'on a raccroché
les gants
la violence s'est terminée mais ça
permet de l'expulser l'espace d'un
moment et le jeu peut être aussi un
moyen de d'expulser symboliquement cette
violence
ouais je rejoins complètement ce que tu
dis mais et du coup ça répond en quelque
sorte à ta question c'est qu'en ayant
joué avec quelqu'un en fait tu connais
pas sa personnalité dans le jeu tous les
morts parce que tu as vraiment eu
affaire à une facette de sa personnalité
avec des règles très précises et donc
quand les règles de la vie de tous les
jours
arrive la personne se comporte
différemment et je pense d'ailleurs que
ça peut être un danger entre guillemets
pour les gens qui jouent qui font que
jouer moi je suis plus joueur mais je
pense tout est arrangé pour les gens qui
font que jouer toute leur vie c'est qu'à
un moment donné peut-être qu'ils
n'arrivent plus à trop faire la
dissociation entre ce que c'est un jeu
quand tu jouais quand tu ne joues pas en
fait oui et ça c'est vrai qu'il peut
faire attention à ça peut-être est-ce
que jouer aux échecs rend plus
intelligent alors je pose la question de
manière volontairement provocatrice mais
j'ai envie de laisser libre d'euros
alors je dirais ça de la manière
suivante joue aux échecs te donne une
méthode de pensée c'est à dire que quand
tu fais face à un problème
la méthode de pensée simple premièrement
je m'arrête je réfléchis je le prends le
problème j'y vais pas tout de suite je
m'arrête je réfléchis je regarde bien le
problème auquel je fais face je
regardais j'évalue les le cheminement de
choses que j'ai à faire pour faire face
au problème et je mets après en route
les manières technique de le résoudre
mais c'est à dire qu'en fait au moment
où je vais commencer à faire mon premier
pas pour résoudre le problème qui me
fait face
je vais de déjà connaître le pas numéro
5 et le pas numéro 6 ans et on va dire
que les échecs ça te donne ça te donne
ça en fait ça te rend pas plus
intelligent mais quand on me pose un
problème n'importe quoi dans la vie tous
les jours un problème de maths imprègne
de fil aux problèmes de quoi que ce soit
c'est à dire à temps avant d'écrire
avant de faire quoi que ce soit on va
regarder le truc on va regarder où le
solutionner on va voir combien d'étapes
qui va falloir faire pour le solutionner
et une fois qu'on aura compris le nombre
d'étapes on va commencer à faire l'étape
1 puis l'étape depuis l'étape 3 et à la
fin de chaque étape on va peut être
réévaluée pour voir si on peut améliorer
la suite regarde ça donne ça l'échec en
fait ça donne une manière de
de penser le comme le comme d'autres
choses peuvent te la donne et bien sûr
nos sûr mais c'est vrai qu'il ya souvent
cette idée qui consiste à dire que soit
il faudrait être plus intelligent que
les autres pour nos échecs ou soit que
ça rendrait plus intelligent donc
finalement ta réponse est intéressante
et satisfaisant dans le sens où c'est ma
question d'intelligence
c'était un petit peu leur je vais
t'emmener pas question d'intelligence on
est bien d'accord mais par contre la
réponse sur la méthode de pensée c'est
intéressant parce que c'est vrai qu'on
peut utiliser nos capacités dans les
échecs en dehors des échecs
oui d'ailleurs quand jose sharks tu le
fais tout le temps tu fais tout le temps
moi tout ressemble à une partie d'échecs
en fait alors que nancy pas sur ma
dernière question avant ça avant la
dernière question je vais te citer trois
noms et tu vas me dire voilà celle profs
et tu vas me dire pourquoi je les cite
ces trois noms bobby fischer akiba
rubinstein vol morphy alors selon vous
pourquoi j'ai associé ces trois noms je
fais semblant de réfléchir
honnêtement non non c'est vrai elle
enfin je sais qu'ils sont des grands
joueurs d'échecs et qu' ils ont tous
marqué leur époque
une manière x ou y mais c'est une
manière x ou y qui va nous intéresser en
sélection mais qu'est-ce qui avaient fui
les objets chers winstein morphy en fait
ses fils et rubinstein qui me quittent
eux qui rentre pas dans la liste
en fait je connais pas trop son histoire
a alors et booth mais dont l'autre côté
sinon oui c'est un peu fou fou mais qui
souffre de manière complètement en
opposé en fait d'après ce que je sais
alors explique ont un peu donc
oui j'ai cité trois noms de joueurs
l'échec réputé réputé 1 je dis bien
parce que j'ai pas porter de jugement
lipsic hattrick ni moral ni quoi que ce
soit d'ailleurs réputé à avant sombrer
dans une forme de folie séquelles
parallèlement des grands champions
d'échecs alors bobby fischer si vous
nous expliquer un petit peu lui bobby
fischer ouais il est devenu un bon déjà
il faut quand même revenir sur ce qui
est bobby fischer ouais c'est
probablement le plus grand génie vente a
toujours des gens qui vont dire oui non
mais c'est probablement le plus grand
génie des échecs qui existait avec
murphy d'ailleurs je pense
bon après c'est sûr difficile mais où
ils font partie des gens exceptionnels
bobby fischer notamment parce que il a
réussi à étudier tout seul les échecs
chez lui aux états unis avec les
bouquins et il a fait face à toute
l'école soviétique face est un homme
seul c'est rocky balboa des échecs
c'est impressionnant parce
qu'aujourd'hui on va dire karl scène
machin tu allais pas non plus enfin ya
plus cette histoire même d'union
soviétique mais ce que je veux dire
c'est que en fait bobby fischer sait on
à une époque qu'on n'a pas trois que ça
l'information aujourd'hui tu te
connectes sur internet on est tous plus
ou moins à égalité tout le monde a accès
à l'information la bobby fischer c'est
juste impressionnant ces machines aux
états unis il est face à une armée de
gens qui ont une méthodologie une école
un truc extraordinaire et qui sont
entraînés et là tu as un mec seul qui
étudie et qui arrivent et qui dit en
fait non et puis tu vois c'est pas juste
pas 1-0 ou 2-0
c'est j'arrive des joueurs comme time à
9 h de mai 6 0 sur glace est cassée
j'écrase tout le monde en partant de
très loin jusqu'à ce match contre
spassky ou d'ailleurs à mon avis on fera
pas l'histoire mais c'est parce qu'ils
étaient peut-être un peu au dessus il
avait bien
il avait bien le bon style de jeu on va
pas rentrer dans les détails mais pour
le contrer mais après fischer elle a peu
fait du fisher du cinéma il a fait
changer de piastre si les gens sont
intéressés par le match de 72 ils
regarderont pas leur part le même faire
conseil le film pawn sacrifice
et après il a commencé à devenir
complètement parano fisher et loyers
tomber dans l'antisémitisme
on peut le dire alors là par un bilingue
c'est intéressant parce que justement la
paranoïa c'est une forme de folie alors
je mets des guillemets je précise aux
auditeurs on va pas être dans des termes
ultra précis parce que on va pas faire
une vidéo sur le thème de la folie c'est
simplement pour comprendre la paranoïa
je trouve que c'est une manière
cohérente d'être fou pour un joueur
d'échecs ce que tu comment pourquoi je
dis ça je pense j'aurais dit la même
chose que toi mais j'aimerais bien voir
de la part d'un amata pourquoi ça c'est
un mamadou dia s'est lié à la capacité
d'imaginer des scénarios possibles et
des échecs repose sur la possibilité
d'anticiper plein de situations allie
plaisir
donc quand il ya des possibilités
infinies automatiquement ben je trouve
que c'est pas illogique de tomber dans
une forme de paranoïa parce qu'on va
partir du principe que tout est possible
il ya pas de ya pas de frein à notre
imagination
ouais tu vois donc jeu et puis en plus
ça les échecs et en fait pour chacun
vaincre l'autre bon bah c'est aussi des
possibilités qui pèsent sur toi c'est
une menace
je pense que je suis en colère je peux
tu peux je peux te raconte hewitt était
vraiment clair d'ailleurs est marrant en
tant qu'amateur que tu es plus
comprendre ça fera monter une petite
anecdote que je peut-être même jamais
racontre rencontres à compter les
milliers de vidéos que j'ai fait à
l'exclusive yvelines exclusivité mais a
il m'arrive toujours eu de rivales il
m'arrive est toujours un truc bizarre
quand je jouais un coup aux échecs c'est
toi tu calcules et où tu réfléchis genre
tu es là tu réfléchis 30 minutes 40
minutes parfois tu joues ton cou et il
m'est toujours arrivé un truc qui me
pouvais me rendre vraiment fou mais
vraiment fou c'est quand j'avais
réfléchi longtemps à seulement tu joues
ton cou et au moment où tu appuies sur
la pendule
t'as ton cerveau qui te fait alerte
rouge et qui tenait plein de
possibilités que tu avais pas vus genre
ouais mais là il y avait ça dans son
élan il y avait ça y avait ça et la
plupart du temps c'est juste des quoi à
la con entre guillemets qui marche pas
du tout les changer tous ce moment où je
joue une fille ton cou est temps que tu
as l'impression que je suis pas ton
cerveau est en pointe à 2
deux messages d alerte n'avait pas prévu
ce scénario je n'ai pas prévu ce
scénario
et ouais enfin ça peut rendre parano
qu'au bout d'un moment ça préfet et
justement où j'appuie je reviens j'écris
mon couple ce que tu écris ton qu après
je regarde la position et soudain coup
ça après coup droit juste après juste
après juste avant et ouais est ce qui
rend parano c'est qu'en fait aux échecs
il ya rien le la dynamique du jeu est
telle que si tu joues 30 coups excellent
et un très mauvais coup tu vas perdre en
fait le prix d'un mauvais coup le prix
d'une erreur est gravissime
en fait une partie d'échec quand tu
joues à très haut niveau comme fisher et
tout ça pour la gagner il faut jouer pas
refait de a à z
en fait même si le mec en face toujours
parfait parfait parfait parfait parfait
l'autre ils jouent bien bien bien bien
bien donc juste un peu en dessous et toi
tu fais une erreur grave en fait une
erreur grave
c'est beaucoup plus grave que enfin tu
vois c'est aux échecs c'est punitif en
fait tu peux pas faire une émeute a pas
le droit t'as pas loin de faire d'erreur
chaque jeu pour les grosses cartes n'a
pas le droit et donc forcément fait ce
fait se trouve pas c'est vrai que dans
toutes tes parties fait pas jamais le
droit à l'erreur faite c'est s'est
jamais pardonné et donc en fait c'est un
brise ccfa ça rend fou dames enfin oui
j'ai meilleur ton explication par
rapport à ça mais après cette façon ça
qu'on est pas mal donc on avait dit
également polymorphie qui s'est passé
avec profit alors paul murphy de ce que
j'ai lu mais alors il est pas forcément
devenu sous par rapport aux échecs à lui
il a une histoire un peu tu veux que je
suis pas spécialiste de
de morphine mais en fait un bond il a
battu toulon deux échecs il est bien en
europe
il a écrasé tout le monde après il avait
des problèmes parce que le meilleur
joueur de l'époque staunton il refusait
de jouer contre lui j'ai dit non je ne
jouerai pas contre paul morphine n'est
pas assez fort bon il a juste gagné tous
les tournois mais tu vois c'est un peu
politique un peu comme le sport
affrontant le sport façon ça a toujours
été un peu politique et non pas que les
échecs et donc il se protégeait un peu
comme celle d'henry non moi je vais
prendre tel adversaire
ce que j'ai avec fabien je vais donner
moi le titre de champion du monde
d'échecs après addition que le passant
là dans la rue très bien lui pour faire
un nouveau match de championnat du monde
il a pris hier très très doux et gratuit
c'est un peu le délire pas assez bon et
donc après les parties des échecs mais
je crois surtout qu'il était doté d'une
intelligence incroyable et qu'il voulait
et je crois qu'il voulait être juris en
louisiane alors là attention les
commentaires je peux dire des bêtises et
justes en fait il était archi contre l'
esclavage des personnes de couleur
n'étaient pas forcément très bien vu en
louise elle j'ai pas hésité à autre
chose sur ta fiche mais j'avoue de
choses mais j'ai mal notés j'arrive pas
à me relire navré on n'y a plus de
devenir fou pour pour d'autres raisons
mais si ce que j'ai alors pouvoir se
vendre sur renault fait pour l'euro
restera au bon endroit alors rubinstein
rubinstein lui j'ai lu dans la liste
parce que de ce que j'ai vu souffrir
d'une timidité maladive
dès que son adversaire devait jouer il
partait se cacher peut-être la pièce
pour ne pas déranger sur l'adversaire
c'est extraordinaire ça j'adore me
laissait pas non j'ai marqué négoce
voilà donc c'est ce que j'ai lu après je
n'ai jamais cessé
ça m'étonnerait par une extraordinaire
c'est pas mal mais donc ça me rentrer
dedans et ça parte ligne 3 entre entre
fischer rubinstein est mort fille on a
quand même des formes de folie qui sont
assez différentes
alors le but était pas ici de résoudre
la question de la folie n'est moi ma
question c'est est est-ce qu'ils
auraient une corrélation entre les
échecs et la folie c'est une question
qui aurait été peut-être un peu brutale
si je l'avais pousser comme ça sans
préparation
jc exemple qu'est-ce que tu en conclut
écoute les joueurs d'échecs sont
un peu fou fou à leur manière après il y
a il ya plein de manières différentes en
fait de voir cette question après on va
peut-être entrer dans l'ain peu un
politiquement correct je laisserais
publier située ou pas on verra mais mais
j'ai un ami qui avait fait un article
très intéressant sur pourquoi les hommes
sont plus forts que les femmes aux
échecs et il avait pris pleins
d'articles et de matériel qu'ils avaient
pu trouver et en fait je pense que
c'était le directeur d'harvard d'une
autre grande école qui disait qu'il y
avait souvent des profils chez les gens
hyper intelligent masculin plus souvent
que féminin parce que les hommes étaient
plus souvent atteints de maladie mentale
et que les gens atteints de maladie
mentale était souvent dotés d'une
intelligence pouvait être doté d'une
intelligence bien supérieur et comme
pour très bien joué aux échecs il faut
être très intelligent
peut-être que c'est plutôt au début la
maladie après du coup les échecs ça fait
qu'aggraver d'accord du coup en fait
nous dans tout ce qu'on a eue sur toutes
les explications de pourquoi les hommes
étaient plus fortes que les femmes aux
échecs c'était l'explication sur les
maladies mentales c'était une
explication qu'il allait le plus lui
parce que ça avec les effets des joueurs
d'échecs sont très très fort il y en a
un certain nombre qui sont un peu foufou
et du pussy être un peu fou fou c'est
souvent corrélée avec le fait d'être une
très intelligent mouais ça pourrait ce
ça pourrait se lire mais bon brussels
est ce que alors là on va réparer une
émission de psychologie aux deux
cicatrices mais est ce que ce n'est pas
l'intelligence qui seraient responsables
de leur folie au contraire au sens où si
l'intelligence et la capacité à explorer
des pistes de raisonnement infinie au
bout d'un moment tout ça se mélange
peut-être et tout ça crée la de la
confusion mentale je dis pas que c'est
ça l'explication mais tu vois je trouve
ça quand même assez curieux comme comme
quand le silence parce que ça reste des
coïncidences qu'on trouve les des cas de
champion du monde qui est juste
c'est un qui soit qu'ils aient sombré
dans la folie donc polymorphie on a
retrouvé entre temps sur la fin de sa
vie il souffrait de délires de
persécution et de paranoïa
ouais après mais il a eu une vie
mouvementée difficile et à la fin il est
peut-être devenu auquel vient bien
fourbe ont en tout cas c'était céder une
piste voilà si les gens ont envie
d'aller explorer cette question parce
que c'est une question large et hyper
intéressant je pense sur laquelle on va
se permettre d'être aussi les geckos
seconde a été aujourd'hui la donc dans
cette vidéo pour sa meilleure vouga
ouais je voulais aborder le truc non
mais c'est vrai c'est vrai que c'est
intéressant mais tu sais juste pour pour
conclure comme utiliser quand être
intelligente at teint tu explores
beaucoup de possibilités tout ça donc
c'est le cas forcément mais je pense
aussi que quand tu es dans un milieu
quelques quelque part pour être
confortable il faut être dans la moyenne
ça a été prouvé les gens qui sont dans
la moyenne sont plus dans le confort
mais ça doit être une torture d'être
aussi intelligent mais c'est une torture
juste falaise c'est ça d'être
hallucinant tu parle avec les gens tu
dois comprendre des choses que personne
ne comprend oui mais c'est hyper
confortable ouais c'était très
inconfortable avec doit se passer des
choses que tu dois avoir des choses même
dans ton entourage propres enfin oui
mais tu sais ce soit rendre fou en fait
ouais très concrètement en fait juste le
fait d'être très intelligent c'est
embêtant
je pense que oui tu suivi des parts de
virgin stores sa bêta pas en fait alors
pour vol à la fin de l'entretien qu'il
est donc en 1997 10 blu est le premier
ordinateur à battre le champion du monde
d'échecs qui était garé caspar
d'irrigation d'où ma question quelle est
la place de la créativité dans les
échecs réactivité c'est à dire capacité
créative
est ce que ce n'est pas un jeu purement
mécanique puisque des machines peuvent
gagner à la question très intéressant et
très philosophique à
sur lesquelles on va voir un petit peu
philosophe est d'ailleurs question ultra
intéressante
le truc c'est qu'il y avait plusieurs
périodes dans les échecs différentes
dans les échecs romantique on peut
importer juge voulait partir sur le mot
romantique en fait qu'est ce qu'il ya
d'intéressant
nous les êtres humains on a tous
l'impression qu'il ya une part de hasard
que tout se passe x ou y eu je sais pas
tiens ça c'est très fins et très jolie
là j'ai été très imaginatif on a
l'impression en fait que notre côté
humain d'après notre côté humain c'est
un truc en plus c'est qu'en fait ça nous
rend supérieur et machin est quoi ce
truc en plus la recette imagination
cette créativité cette beauté d'esprit
et en fait on se rend compte aux échecs
que sa beauté d'esprit qu'en fait c'est
juste de la merde que mathématiquement
tu te fais défoncer par un ordinateur
parce qu'il n'ya aucune émotion que tes
émotions te servent à rien qu'à elle de
desserts en fait que tu es fatigué qu'en
fait tu fais des rapprochements entre
une position acte a vu une position b
mais qu'en fait là il ya un tout petit
détail tactique que toi t'as pas vu
parce qu'en fait un débile fini et que
l'ordinateur lui qui a vu cent fois plus
vite que toi et qu'en fait lui il a vu
le détail et que donc tu en sois disant
finesse de compréhension de vision en
fait c'est de la merde aussi et donc en
fait on se rend compte si tu vas avec
les échecs que cette très belle
intelligence humaine quentin une
intelligence informatique qui est ultra
puissante parce qu'elle a besoin de
beaucoup plus calculé que nous en fait
elle nous écrase parce que nous c'est
vrai qu'on est très fort parce qu'on a
de l'imagination et tout ça c'est vrai
que c'est une qualité
mais face à une chose qui peut voir
toutes les possibilités de tout ce qui
peut se passer pas aller beaucoup plus
efficace que nous et donc oui c'est
assez flippant parce qu'aujourd'hui la
créativité aux échecs
c'est devenu quoi c'est devenu dans une
position de faire tourner l'ordinateur
chez soi pour que l'ordinateur
le couple est trouvé avec l'ordinateur
puis surprendre l'adversaire
c'est dire qu'en fait c'est en fait
c'est un peu ce que dit kasparov c'est
que c'est l'homme qui va utiliser
l'ordinateur un fauteuil par un peu dans
le délire de matrix en disant ouais il
faut que les hommes et les ordinateurs
collaborent entre eux ou quoi bref c'est
bien gentil mais au bout d'un moment
tan dung qui font face à cheval c'est
comme si un mec hyper musclé qui vient
et puis tu as un petit qui à un moment
donné à une idée enfin et du coup c'est
hyper flippant dans le monde dans lequel
elle arrive aujourd'hui parce que j'ai
l'impression que dans les échecs
justement on est un peu en avance sur le
monde réel parce qu'on a un jeu qui
correspond bien à l'intelligence
informatique donc pour un ordinateur il
ya des solutions plus ou moins fini et
donc c'est facile de calculer mais on se
rend compte que plus l'ordinateur
progresse plus l'homme s'efface en fait
aujourd'hui dans les échecs mais les
parties de haut niveau c'est souvent je
les caricaturer mais pour pour pour que
tout le monde comprenne mais c'est
souvent celui qui a le mieux répéter
sont hors de son nid des ordinateurs et
qui a pu le mieux la mettre en place
ça c'est vraiment on réussira et il a
joué presque comme l'ordinateur waouh
quel exploit bravo c'est ça en fait s'il
a réussi à répéter ce qu'il avait étudié
avec l'ordinateur shenley imagine c'est
l'ordinateur qui nous apprend à jouer et
en réalité qu'est ce qui va arriver dans
la vie de demain à mon avis ça va être
ça c'est des algorithmes en fait c'est
les algorithmes qui pensent pour toi
c'est eux qui te met des buts quand tous
ton téléphone et il m'a dit ah ouais
c'est vrai car j'avais envie d'acheter
une lampe en fait toi tu avais même
oublié c'est lui qui te rappelles et tu
vas acheter talent tu vas cliquer parce
que en fait tout le truc va être fait
pour te manipule et en réalité mais
c'est justement peut être un toit dans
les échecs on le voit déjà ça fait
l'ordinateur est tellement intelligent
est tellement fin intelligent à sa
manière il est tellement plus adapté à
un tas de problèmes que notre cerveau
qu'en fait il se met à penser à notre
place et nous on est juste là pour faire
la micro le micro truc qui va faire
qu'il va fonctionner un peu mieux où qui
va un peu l'améliorer et j'ai
l'impression qu'on est à l'avant-garde
en fait du monde qui nous attend demain
dans le monde réel en fait ça a l'air un
monde qui va être contrôlé en réalité
par les algorithmes et les ordinateurs
avec une toute petite touche humaine
alors on va te faire croire que la
touche humaine c'est ce qui fait la
différence mais en fait c'est le micro
qu'un de sable tu vois c'est le truc en
fait qui voit là bas c'est juste pour
eux juste parce qu'on est là quoi mais
en fait pas besoin en bois et c'est un
peu faim je pousse un peu la même chose
est d'ailleurs aujourd'hui si tu veux
vraiment voir des parties de haut niveau
fait souvent la blague avec mon copain
fabien enfin fait jouer ton ordinateur
chez toi ce sera mieux que carlson
kasparov fischer mort fille a réuni
ferais tu sors ma bécane qui est juste
en dessous de moi c'est beaucoup mieux
que tous les champions du monde réunis
ensemble qui vont réfléchir pendant une
semaine au courant je fais tourner dix
minutes il est plus fort ah c'est toi
c'est un peu ridicule mais
tu veux voir des parties de haut niveau
mais ton ordi quoi donc mais ben voila
mais plus largement je pense que les
échecs on est vraiment je veux insister
là dessus on est vraiment au aux avant
postes de ce qui nous attend avec cette
intelligence artificielle qui est qui
est juste impressionnante et qui
remplace s'attribuer qui remplace entre
imagination de sujets maintenant l'aider
il écoulé nouveau coup les coûts
créative qu'on trouve alors il ya une
touche humaine mais c'est très
souffrante façon ce sera vérifiée à
l'ordinateur ce sera ré analyser
l'ordinateur et l'ordinateur il va
montrer plein de trucs en fait tu es un
homme n'aurait jamais vu donc voilà très
bien qu'on allait la ville de bombay que
je n'ai pas grand chose à ajouter
tu as répondu au delà de la question que
feront exploser donc c'est parfait
en fait ça c'est anticiper sur la
question de l'intelligence artificielle
des algorithmes et sur notre nos points
faibles dans certains domaines face à la
machine
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui par exemple on
fait des calculs avec la calculatrice on
jouerait sa ridicule de faire à la main
des calculs un final pour dire regardez
j'ai fait aussi bien que la calculatrice
j'aimerais j'ai compté aussi bien calme
sauf qu'il m'a fallu six mois on
trouvait ça ridicule et chaque enfant un
peu ça qu'on fait ça mais après ça reste
un jeu ouais mais en fait on s'amuse on
aime bien regarder et et comme on dit au
foot comme j'ai un père d'origine
italienne dont tu as un beau match de
foot quand on dit on perd c'est 1-0
enfin sinon c'est foutrement à jouer
metheny toujours foot de bandeira s'il
n'y a pas d'erreur il n'y a pas de but
ouais donc c'est pour ça que quand il ya
un match à quatre cas tu vois d'origine
italienne forcément acquis et quels
mauvais match quoi parle d'un contrôle
de but passage ou trop mal en fait c'est
pas possible donc pas la beauté par la
beauté du jeu demandé par en fait ouais
quand tu vas à regagner des parties
d'ordinateurs s'ils jouent vraiment bien
il ya à payer pas des rares en fait la
valeur
donc c'est pas beau pas de box et voilà
c'est ça donc du coup c'est pour ça
qu'ont les joueurs du mahb joue entre
eux c'est sympa parce qu'il ait fait une
erreur c'est vrai que si on garde les
émotions on va appeler certains coûts
des jolis coups
surprenante et inattendue que ça c'est
d'un point de vue humain avec des
émotions et donc à des faiblesses et
comme tu disais tout à l'heure
l'algorithme police n'ose pas la
question
le bailleur poussé le meilleur oeil les
sens ça m'intéresse car at beaucoup
effectivement lui quand tu joues contre
lui juste il te défonces s'en fout
complètement c'est ça ne m'intéresse pas
mais c'est beaucoup plus efficace comme
approche
c'est juste pour ça qu'ils lisent et
qu'on fait notre côté humain on a
l'impression de se vanter que c'est
génial par des évolutions et tout ça
mais d'un point de vue purement
efficacité ou que serait un enfant ou à
l'être humain en bas âge qui à apprendre
et à jouer aux échecs en ayant comme
professeur un ordinateur je sais pas ce
que ça pourrait donner c'est une
question intéressante en fait mais je
sais pas ce que ça pourrait même jeu
j'imagine qu'ils vont qui vont créer des
algorithmes pour que les ordinateurs
puissent apprendre mais j'imagine qu'ils
vont s'adapter pour que c'est comme ils
font quoi te mettre des bonus ou quoi
justement pour te booste et on arrive à
la fin de cet entretien parce que tu
aurais un message à laisser aux gens qui
nous écoutent et notamment à la jeunesse
par rapport aux échecs ou en général
toujours un message à la jeunesse soit
de renoncer par les échecs pour toute
chose et puis enchaîner sur jose c'est
comme tu veux j'aurai plein de choses à
10 avec pas grand chose à la fois elle
mais je peux faire une phrase simple et
qui pourra paraître bizarre pour tout le
monde tu fais ce que tu veux
aimez vous les uns les autres merci
merci
[Musique]